i'm on to tuesday
all
understanding
today is
if
he has to read it out i just want to
know where you get your bougie uh
thumb camera straps this is
called amazon
30 or 40 countries over the last 10
years
yeah i've i've had i'm doing just fine
right one time
i had my strap
and my 7200 district right into the
concrete
i don't know
okay okay
um
dude i got a full position
hey
oh
i just want to get the top of it
on top of it
um
[Music]
hmm
okay
so
hey
welcome back
last
[Music]
you know what what was happening here
at the beginning yeah you know
coronavirus stuff at the beginning and
then
saturday's session in august on the
postal certificate yeah
yeah recess has been killed yeah
at least the senate
sometimes
just one
um
little
[Music]
oh
so
right there
it's your guest today
[Music]
copy
[Music]
uh
objects
[Music]
she's waiting for sure
no i was just saying that this is
later
um
it was like
[Music]
oh
man
um
okay
um
[Music]
he's in a great room thank you
thank you
okay
um
so
[Music]
you
sometimes
[Music]
uh
thanks
good morning everyone it's about a week
quite a week i'm so proud of our members
who are busy at work
especially our chairmen organizing their
committees
to get ready for our our bill that we
anticipate will become law
as soon as possible the american
rescue plan put forth by president
president biden as a part of
as part of how we meet the needs of the
american people
the pandemic and the economic crisis
that go with it uh it continues to be
devastating
to the american people this legislation
is necessary but don't take my word
for it yesterday the chairman of the
federal reserve stated that the real
unemployment rate is 10
matching the worst point in the great
recession
in his speech he said for recovery
fiscal policy is an essential tool
for this situation he referenced that
monetary policy
would not be enough chairman powell
played down the fears
of inflation during the pandemic and
noted that in his words
inflation has been much has been much
lower and more stable over the past
three decades
than in earlier times and that he did
not expect it to accelerate in a
sustained way
coming out of the pandemic as chairman
powell
said given the number of people who have
lost their jobs the likelihood that some
will struggle to find work
in the pandemic economy in the
post-pandemic economy
achieving a sustaining maximum
employment will require
more than supportive monetary policy
it will require a society-wide
commitment hence
the legislation that our members are
working on this week
we hope to finish our markups in
committee this week and then
send it to the budget committee next
week for them to
do work their will on it then to the
rules committee
and then to the floor and we hope to
have this all done
by the end of february certainly
uh on the president's desk in time
to offset the
march 14th deadline where some
unemployment benefits will expire
i'm particularly interested in how women
are affected by the pandemic but also
by this legislation over 2.3
million women have been forced to leave
the workforce
entirely including 1 million moms
that's why this bill is so important
because it has
a strong commitment to child care
so that parents moms and dads
are able to go to work as a strong
commitment
to getting our kids back to school
another
path to the workforce for moms
last month january nearly
80 percent of workers who left the
workforce were women and in december
it was 90 percent of those who had left
the workforce
were women the women's labor force
participation rate
is now just about 57 the lowest level
in 33 years for women of color the
situation is
even worse
again that is about the livelihood of
the american people about the lives of
the american people
i talked about 10 percent unemployment
as quoted by the chairman of the fed
chairman powell another number that is
just so somber
uh sobering is 470 000 americans
have died of the coronavirus 470
thousand again this legislation that
we're passing now
so addresses the needs of the american
people when it comes
to the coronavirus it's about the lives
and the livelihood of the american
people we're proud again of our
committee chairs who are
moving ahead expeditiously with nine
committees working
on marking up legislation for the
american rescue plan this week they're
moving forward to crush the virus
the funding there for uh for virus
production distribution for testing etc
for other funding in terms of access to
health care
again the goal is to put vaccines in
people's arms
children back in school workers back in
their jobs and money
in people's pockets and the money in
people's pockets
were very br proud that in the
legislation
we in the house the education labor
committee marked up its bill
on tuesday until 4 a.m wednesday morning
a big part of money in people's pockets
in the education and labor committee
in addition to making our schools safe
for our children to go back to school
they've great in the bill it gradually
raises the minimum wage to 15
an hour increases paychecks in doing so
increases paychecks for
27 million workers
and pulling nearly a million people out
of poverty
well over 50 percent closer to
two-thirds or 70 percent
of people making the minimum wage are
women
many of them women of color again it
secures the child tax credits helping
nearly one in three adults having
trouble paying for households expenses
and 12 million children from going
hungry
so in the legislation we have the child
tax
credit this is quite remarkable three
thousand dollars
for a child uh a child and then six
they're six years and under it is uh
thirty six hundred dollars this is
pulling these children out of poverty
the bill also addresses those who are
food insecure
rental rent insecure and the rest so
it's a very important piece of
legislation it is what this country
needs
and i salute uh not only the president
and vice president for their leadership
in recognizing that in this important
work
uh but also to do so in a way that is
robust meets the needs of the american
people
but also meets the needs of of the
strength of our economy
we plan as i said to work on it this
week next week
and have it passed by the end of
february
and so we can send it to the president's
desk before the unemployment benefits
expire
this week as you know we have seen uh
it's been such a sad
time for us but at this as we see what
is being presented we also see the
extraordinary valor
of the capitol police who risked and
gave their lives to save our
capital our democracy our lives
they are martyrs for our democracy
martyrs for our democracy those who lost
their lives
that is why i am putting forth a
resolution
introducing legislation to pay tribute
to the capitol police and other law
enforcement
of personnel who protected the capital
by giving them a congressional gold
medal
the highest honor that congress can
bestow
the service of the capitol police force
that day brings honor
to our democracy they're accepting this
reward
brings luster to this medal we must
always remember
their sacrifice and stay vigilant
against what i've said before about what
abraham lincoln said
the silent artillery of time we will
never forget uh we were
so moved by
having the family give us the honor of
honoring brian
sicknick uh also the living good family
and the smith family
we share their grief and we want to
recognize the valor of that and then
also
of course uh officer goodman
for his his valor but these are
demonstrations of
much more um
bravery uh throughout the capitol
uh on that sad day so we want to honor
them
in the best way that we possibly can and
we will continue to do so beyond a medal
but in our hearts so again we uh
as a senate is dealing with its business
at hand
i'm so proud of our our um
just overwhelmingly proud of our
managers led by jamie
raskin but at the same time we're
getting our work done
to meet the needs of the american people
to crush the virus
put our children back in school money in
people's pockets again
people back to work the lives and the
livelihood of the american people
are our responsibility 470
000 people have died we have to
we have to call a halt uh to that
any questions let me see yes will the
bill that you send
to the senate have a fifteen dollar
minimum wage yes it will
yes we're very proud of that as i said
27 million people will get a raise 70
percent of them
women and uh we will be sending that yes
sir
yeah obviously
compelling presentation
i have not said anything you haven't
heard me talk about impeachment in the
past weeks leading up to this
they are making the case i'm not going
to be responding to what happened
yesterday
or what might happen today except to
salute them
for the
we are of them so i won't be answering
any questions
yeah but if that doesn't convince
republicans
60 seconds what does that say but you
know
again let's let's let the price let's
let's let the
uh the presentation work its way out
american people
we're in a court of uh the senate right
now we're also in the court of public
opinion
when the court of our families will make
judgments about us in our court
of history yes sir your estimation
why was the capital not better prepared
for the potential
of violence on generous sick why was
national guard not called
familiar with what's on the internet now
about what the
secretary of defense said in response to
the request
for the national guard this will all be
pi this morning i was briefed again
by general honore and we're so
honored and blessed by his service and
and another general general singh who's
working with him
on making some recommendations to us
about how we go forward and and that
will be part of the commission
to review uh the command and control
the interagency uh cooperation or lack
thereof one important thing would be
really good
if the state if washington dc if the
district of columbia
could operate as a state as any governor
can do
is to call out the national guard
without getting the permission
of the federal government it shouldn't
have to happen that way
and if you see the letter december
excuse me january fourth letter from the
secretary of defense saying what he
wasn't going to do
if it's it's most unfortunate but i
think everything has to be subjected
to the harshest review to make sure this
doesn't come again
we couldn't be in better hands than
general honore who has such experience
and command so much respect in this
regard
and then further to that uh to pursue a
longer term
what general honore is recommending to
us is the here and now
but a larger uh look at how we got here
where we go from here a couple weeks ago
you said that the enemy is within the
house of representation
given that do you feel comfortable is
that the enemy is within
within within i didn't say that you feel
comfortable
inviting president biden to give his
joint address can you explain
the hold up is it due to public
precautions or is it largely because of
these
violations of the floor that we've been
seeing
it'll be up to again everything that we
do in this regard
in terms of security etc relating to
covet and relating
uh to uh security security is in the
hands of the sergeant arms
and the capitol police and the uh
uh a capital physician
and so they'll make a recommendation
about how we're able to do that
spatially i mean how how many people
when we swore in members on
opening day only the freshman members
the brand new freshman members
were able to have a um a guest
a child a parent not even a child of a
certain age older child or parent
they are only the new members i as new
speaker of the house couldn't have any
family member there to see me sworn in
as speaker so
they decide what that number is and what
that
criteria what the criteria are for it
and same thing will hold for the
president coming to make a state of the
union address
that we won't be doing any of that until
we pass our covet bill that's the first
order of business
yes sir madam speaker with so many
republican senators indicating that
they're prepared to vote for acquittal
what other
avenues of accountability do you think
there will be and would you like to see
for former president trump
i don't i'm not as i say that our our uh
this uh pursuit of justice and truth is
in the hands
of our of our managers and i
i i'm not i will have some things to say
maybe next week
but not this week but let's just see how
what what the case is and
what their response is to it but i'm not
acting upon something that hasn't
happened yet
you have mentioned the position the
commission for sure
that has nothing to do with president
trump that has to do with
what you asked about it's about the
security
how did this happen where do we go from
here and it also
it also will talk about
white supremacy because
there are many instances leading up to
this that could have been indicative
that this could happen acts of violence
around the country springing from that
that's not to say this is only about
anti-semitism and white supremacy
it could be about some other things
we'll see and and
how that was uh provoked but in terms of
the commission
uh we're listening to folks about what
answers
we need in that regard particularly
listening to general honore
about what would be the most useful to
protect us
as we as we go forward yeah but next
week i may have some comments to make
but i'm not uh i haven't said anything
most of our members have not
we've just respected the path of our
managers uh the we couldn't be prouder
of their presentation and we don't want
any
static from any of the rest of us and a
speaker can you address the
one argument that many of the republican
senators are already making and that is
that it's not valid to even have this
trial because you're dealing with
somebody who's a former president
and yet you in the house impeached him
before
while he was still a president this act
occurred while he was still president
but the trial shifted till after he left
the white house what do you think about
that argument of
you know an impeachment occurring at one
point but now people saying you can't
try them because the
actual trial didn't uh take place till
afterwards
actually um again this is not into the
guts of the trial but when uh we were
we passed the article of impeachment
and then we were prepared actually lined
up to take it over to the senate
we were told early in the day that the
senate even though they were not in
session could receive
the the article uh and the managers were
prepared to take it over
as they were preparing for that uh they
we got word from the senate that
if it's not in session you cannot bring
it over
and so you have to wait until mitch
mcconnell decides the senate will be
in session which put it off until uh
later until the 19th
and then they decided well let's get our
do this or that and then wait two weeks
uh
in order to to have the uh
the trial so we were ready uh they said
no in fact one of them even said if you
bring it over here and just leave it
with the secretary of the senate
it could be destroyed i don't know if
that's true
they could just ignore it and say we
weren't here
we never got it uh but that it's a
little disingenuous to say
uh that but it's separate and apart from
that as
what i just told you is totally
unnecessary
because the fact is that the senate
voted and the constitution
allows for someone to be tried
after they are no longer in office
or else as jamie said you have a january
exception you got to get out jail free
card do whatever you want
uh as long as the senate is a accomplice
in terms of putting it off
uh uh you're saved but in any event
all that i said about when we were going
and all is
interesting but it's not just positive
of the interest
of the issue because the constitution is
dispositive
of that okay all right well thank you
all very much
thank you
you